whenever I'd go to their house when they
were like little babies I would bring
donuts I don't know why I felt like
that's like a fun thing to bring a kid I
bet their parents loved it when you
brought them sugar oh yeah gone out the
door hey everyone it's Carolina and
today I'm on the side of ABC's The
Company You Keep It Stars Milo and
Amelia and Catherine hennekin Milo plays
a criminal and Catherine plays a CIA
agent as they fall for each other the
lies they tell grow bigger and bigger
The Company You Keep from your Sunday 10
9 Central on ABC and stream on Hulu but
before we all watch that let's see if
Milo and Catherine are as good at lying
as their characters okay so you're each
gonna read three statements and the
other person has to guess which is a lie
May the best liar win I once threw my
shoulder out opening the refrigerator
door and then popped it back into place
myself I wanted to dive into my 30s so I
literally did it diving like skydiving
with my girlfriend and
because you know how cheesy I am so sure
uh and I speak fluent Latin you don't
speak Latin I should I took eight years
of it are you serious yeah but you're
not fluent yeah I covered up for a buddy
who put graffiti on public property and
I actually spent a night in jail I hit
snooze twice on the alarm in the morning
I'm known by my best friend's kids Uncle
donut that one's a lie that's true it's
true yeah that's the truth that is
absolutely the truth I'm Uncle donut
where did that come from one of my
closest friends that I've known since
second grade uh his kids whenever I go
to their house when they were like
little babies I would bring donuts so I
became known as Uncle Donuts they will
in their school like oh yeah my uncle
Donna and then like the teachers find
out like oh it's my events a million but
I'm just Uncle Donuts these kids um and
no I've never I've never spent the night
in jail that was not one it's probably a
week I once got stuck on a subway for
six hours in the middle of August my
middle name henna which is Korean means
beautiful and smart and I once booked a
flight to Europe on a whim and in five
countries and 10 cities in 15 days true
false true the middle name is false nice
middle name but it doesn't mean
beautiful what would it mean garbage I
got donuts
what's that say about me so you didn't
get stuck on a subway for six hours I
didn't I've trained with Navy Seals for
film rules my older sisters used to
dress me up like Madonna I got denied a
job at Disneyland as a kid I feel like
you've trained with Navy Seals that's
false oh but you've trained with I've
trained with special forces uh Army
special horses okay
I think we're both pretty good at lying
I think I I can't do it so I just kind
of don't you can't lie I don't like to
yeah well as you know I have no poker
face so I really can't lie you just kind
of get a surprise look on your face
[Music]